the president is facing divisions among
advisors inside the White House and more
CEO said they would not serve on his
advisory councils mr. Trump announced
yesterday that he is shutting down those
committees Margaret Brennan is near the
trump National Golf Club in New Jersey
where the president returned yesterday
Margaret good morning good morning a
defiant President Trump is attacking
Republican Senator Lindsey Graham and
the press claiming that they falsely
represented his remarks yesterday the
president was forced to dissolve his
business councils after nearly all of
their members quit I stand with the
president and I stand by those words
vice president Mike Pence cut his
foreign trip short to return for
meetings with President Trump as
administration officials work to control
the damage yesterday the president
announced plans to hold one of his
campaign style rallies to shore up
support next Tuesday in Arizona but the
mayor of Phoenix is asking mr. Trump to
delay the event saying that in the wake
of charlottesville it will quote inflame
emotions and further divide our nation
particularly if the president uses the
trip to announce a pardon for
controversial former sheriff joe arpaio
long accused of racially profiling
Latinos he's a good man he was one of
the first endorses of Donald Trump our
piyo is a hero to the so-called
alt-right and many of the white
supremacists who support it in a rare
interview published Wednesday strategist
Steve Bannon described the white
supremacist movement as a quote
collection of clowns but also as
politically useful saying he wants
Democrats to talk about racism every day
if the left is focused on race and
identity and we go with economic
nationalism we can crush the Democrats
we'll see what happens with mr. bannon
but he's a good person
the president's description of ban and
on Tuesday fueled speculation his job is
in jeopardy he has been accused of
leaking damaging information about
fellow White House staff including
economic adviser Gary Cohen who was
visibly dismayed during the president's
Tuesday presser but has no plans to
resign VA secretary Shulkin also said
he's staying
despite personal convictions it is a
dishonor to our country's veterans to
allow the Nazis and the white
supremacist to go unchallenged all
military service branch leaders have
condemned the hate but they have been
careful not to criticize the president
today Ivanka Trump and Jared Kushner
will join President Trump here in New
Jersey they had been away in Vermont for
a few days but had been quick to urge
disavowal of the hate groups and Charlie
tomorrow vice president Pence will join
mr. Trump at Camp David for some
national security-related meetings
thanks Margaret